good sanderson alien hey guys what's up
welcome to behind the scenes were a lien
on your head this is a really weird
video as you probably were able to tell
one actually which is based on a true
story you see we've been practicing a
lot of archery lately basically we
started shooting at targets but to make
things more exciting we started training
to shoot an apple off someone's head
so we'd set up like a helmet and it said
whatever a piece of garbage we had lying
around but you did it as if you're
shooting an apple off somebody's head
there very quickly of stopping an apple
and start being an alien yeah and
basically to hone our reflexes every
once in a while we cry out oh my god
there's an alien on your head and that
would prompt whoever shooting the bow to
shoot at the target as fast as possible
because they knew that one of our lives
were at stake so but if they shot too
low they killed a person yeah so we kind
of ended up basing an entire video off
of that well I mean apparently aliens
have evolved to latch on to humans heads
from many different species across the
galaxy and it just so happened that in
this space warehouse four of those
aliens attacked us simultaneously yeah
and we just had to fight them before he
said really these guns are janky
yeah it's red Cuba like two to three
[Music]
[Laughter]
sharper reaction for the hit actually
alien juice is being poured on my face
and I didn't like it I had to get that
off that's what it felt like on the
inner sole my inner soul guys you need
to be more careful I don't have to go
home to mom cells
I don't have to go to Mom's house my
arms about the dislocation
and gets into the reddit can now write
what you it has give it's not gonna be
the same
[Applause]
[Music]
let's do this Nikko it's okay it's okay
wait lower there we go that looks better
aim it to your right 22
are you alright so you just sawed the
last shot for the shoot and I gotta say
this is probably one of the weirdest
shoots we've ever done
nope yeah yeah but Footloose didn't stem
from like a single joke and a photo on
Twitter I think this is pretty funny
like this falls back to our classic like
sense of humor which is making fun of
filmmaking which sometimes translates
really well and sometimes doesn't yeah I
guess you'll tell us translated I really
liked seeing the opening shots this
piece yeah yeah there we go
freaking sweaty day all right guys we
post cool tweets we post cool faces on
Facebook so yeah there's some sweet
behind-the-scenes photos from the
shooting here on Facebook okay so check
it out go sweet photos and stuff there
and if you're not following us on
Twitter you probably should be because
sometimes you're like wait me do you
think oh this is this really doesn't
this week all right here take the side
follow us on Twitter and answers that
you want to see some really sweet behind
this yeah subscribe if you feel like it
[Music]
you